Those are the words of Klaus Schwab,
head of the World Economic Forum in
COVID 19 the Great Reset.
People assume
we are just going back
to the good old world which we had,
and everything will be normal again
in how we are used
to normal.
And the old fashioned system
is, let's say, fiction.
It will not happen.
At the latest World Economic Forum
meeting in Davos, Schwab set the
tone for the conference with his
glowing introduction of the opening
speaker.
We now welcome
His Excellency Xi
Jinping, president of
the People's Republic of China.
Xi laid out his vision of a
coordinated global economy.
Major economies should
see the world as one community
and coordinate the objectives,
intensity and pace
of fiscal and monetary policies.
This ideal of a united globe
with a coordinated economy managed
by experts captures Schwab's
vision of the post-COVID world.
We have to redefine
our social contract.
These grand proclamations,
the ominous book title and Schwab's
odd personal style have led many
people to speculate that the Great
Reset is part of a conspiracy
of global financial elites and
politicians to depopulate
the planet so they can more easily
institute one world government
or even that COVID was engineered
to that end.
Remember the stated goal by these
people
Billionaire transhumanist elites,
the globalists that all get together
every year.
As the population of the planet,.
A transhumanist revolution
to make people chronically sick that
results in the death of the vast
majority of the world population and
out of that cataclysm,
a new super race.
I don't buy it.
Imagine the amount of coordination
and airtight secrecy needed for
these kinds of far reaching
conspiracies of global domination
to succeed.
They'd be exposed and fall apart,
especially in the age of the
internet, instead of spinning
our wheels searching for a secret
agenda.
Let's just look at the one that's
right out in the open.
I think we are moving from
short term to long term,
from
shareholder capitalism to
stakeholder capitalism.
What China, the World Economic
Forum and Massachusetts Senator
Elizabeth Warren have in common is
that they favor so-called
stakeholder capitalism,
which is the euphemism for making
companies answer first to special
interests.
They want to reorganize corporate
boards to include representatives
from labor, environmental and social
justice groups.
Warren proposed a bill to require
40 percent of large corporate board
seats be elected by workers.
In  China, the state simply owns
or controls a majority stake in
most of the country's largest firms.
The World Economic Forum and many
state leaders believe global
coordination and global governance
is essential to manage global
problems, climate change,
international financial instability
and future pandemics.
A crucial flaw in Schwab's
Great Reset is that it puts
too much faith in the ability of
governments to re-engineer society
in a way that better serves the
needs and desires of all citizens.
He wants a rethinking of capitalism
that escapes the tyranny of GDP
growth so that companies create
goods and services for the common
good instead of maximizing
profits.
The phrase "common good"
points to his fundamental
misunderstanding of capitalism,
which is nothing new.
Central planners were using this
idea to maximize their own power
at the expense of individual freedom
back in the 1940s, when
Nobel Prize winning economist F.A.
Hayek wrote "The Road to Serfdom,"
which would go on to sell over two
million copies.
Every single one of the billions of
people who populate this planet have
unique goals and desires that are
impossible to reduce to a unified
whole. Whether that's GDP or
whatever supposedly holistic metrics
the WEF wants to replace it with,
profits are a signal to
entrepreneurs that they are
satisfying the disparate needs
of their customers.
Schwab is right that the war is the
health of the state.
As the writer Randolph Bourne once
put it, and the government's
response to COVID has been similar
to military conflict in terms of
the cost and the chaos it's
engendered. World Wars one and
two and the Great Depression ushered
in a powerful modern welfare
and warfare state that irreversibly
altered America and the world.
But I'm more optimistic this
time.
Thanks in large part to the power of
technology to provide everyday
citizens with an exit instead
of the Great Reset, in which
sclerotic 20th century institutions
accumulate even more power.
I think we're entering
the Great Escape.
This is possible because
technological progress is outpacing
the ability of the state to control
and regulate it.
Governments will have no choice but
to abandon their efforts to
construct physical and metaphorical
walls.
Technology can be designed to
facilitate decentralization
in which the flow of money and
information can't be controlled.
Ideas emerge from the bottom up,
expecting governments and
international bodies to orient
every large company towards
some widely agreed upon common
good assumes that many of
the very institutions that bungled
that COVID 19 response can
competently handle the planet's
most intractable problems.
My hope is that after witnessing
the colossal failure of governments
in the face of a global crisis, many
more people will be looking for a
different approach.
There's evidence everywhere of the
great escape.
The US population shift away from
expensive, restrictive and poorly
governed states and cities, spurred
on by the rise of remote work.
The exodus from government run
schools, the growing use of
cryptocurrency, the popularity
of encrypted private communication
platforms and the expanding
reach of independent voices in
our increasingly decentralized
media. Hayek called central planning
the fatal conceit, writing
that.
And
Schwab even touches on this idea,
writing that.
He dubs this "quantum
politics," but never quite explains
how policymakers will realistically
overcome this dilemma.
Maybe there's record low trust
in our institutions because the
people running them are attempting
the impossible: planning
the future for billions of people.
Humiliating to preside as it may be,
Hayek wrote in the Constitution of
Liberty.
The fear of a great escape of losing
control is understandable
because there are systemic risks
that could destroy human
civilization, including future
natural or manmade pandemics,
runaway inflation and ecological
disaster.
Small boats may not survive a
storm, but a giant ship
is strong enough to brave a storm.
But if we're all stuck in the same
large ship in the same storm,
we're all going down with it when
the winds finally get bad enough.
Concentrated power itself presents
an existential risk.
A bad intervention applied to
economies of the entire world at
once can bring down the entire
system.
But the distributed power and humble
trial and error of markets and
decentralized governance brings
progress in fits and starts
with less risk of total ruin.
What Schwab, Xi and central
planners around the world miss is
that when securing the rights of the
individual comes first, the rest
tends to follow.
The great escape from the 20th
century is underway
and there might be nothing they can
do to stop it.
The question is, do they make
getting there easy or does it
happen the hard way?